hello everyone and welcome to another
really cool game from the 2019 video
World Cup it's Kingdom vs. sir game
obsession and most Asian was a some ten
years ago he was among the top 10 rated
players in the world with a rating of
some 2751 now he's a bit lower rated but
nevertheless a very very strong opponent
for for ding and two of the classical
games between the two of them have been
wrong this is the first game of the
rapids so without further ado let's
check it out
ding opens with c4 so the English is on
the board with E 5 g3 Knight to f6
Bishop to g2 and now d5 with C captures
Knight captures Knight to f3 and now the
other night is developed with knife to
c6
I'm just lower this a bit with castles
by ding and now Knight back to b6 B 3
ding prepares to fianchetto his a dark
square Bishop and now Bishop to d6
developing preparing the castle also
putting more defense to the e5 pawn
Bishop to b2 and now most Asian castles
we have d3 biding and Queen to e7 with
the idea of trading of the darks for
bishops with Bishop to a3 once the
knight is developed with night b2 b2 and
here there is a there were a few games
that have reached this position Bishop
to g4 is a known move f5 is a known move
here at one of the top engines
recommendations in fact is f5 but most
AC and prepare the brush up to a 314 not
specifically for ding but probably has
no one ever played it before probably he
has this line prepared for someone who
ever you know comes but ok with Bishop
captures Queen captures and now Queen to
c1 ding would very much enjoy trading
Queens here and grab hold of the semi
open C file for his rooks I'm obsession
of course declines this trade with Queen
to e7 and now Queen tabby to freeing up
the C file for the rooks with Bishop to
g4 biome of session and now rook a to C
1 we have rook a to d8 putting a rock on
a semi open D file and now look if the
a1 the knight can now move
as the point is now nicely protected
rook ft8 now all of the pieces are
developed and now with a three taking
away the be Foursquare from blacks
pieces also preparing before with a five
by black button before nonetheless a
capture some be for a captures and now
Knights the d4 and here is where the
part is really starting with Knight
captures on d4 and here most Asian gives
up the pawn with he captures on d4
allowing Dean to capture the b7 point
somewhat well more logical with rook
captures as now if Bishop captures and
b7 you can also capture the pawn on b4
as the Queen is also protecting that but
most Asian I will grab that phone later
he prefers each capture son before now
puts a lot of pressure on the e2 pawn as
it's now a backwards pawn so let's see
how it goes ding accepts the present
with Bishop captures on b7 and now
Knight to a4 attacking dings Queen but
Queen to c2 and now ding is attacking
the knight on a4 and also can you
capture this pawn on b4 well if you
capture with Queen captures and before
you would lose the game because now of
course you will see it to c6 a double
attack on the night when the Queen and
Bishop attack it and also your rook is
under attack so if you don't want to
lose the piece you have to move the
knight somewhere it's not really
attacking anything there now you just
eliminate one of the rooks and you are
up for the exchange black doesn't really
have anything to show for it so black
would be lost here after Queen to c2
with Knight to c3 by move session and
ding now retreats with the Bishop Bishop
to f3 again not allowing the cap run
before as black the bishop on g4 is
under attack with h4 defending it
Bishop captures H captures and now
tonight's the b3 and here's where it
really becomes interesting it's a rapid
games you can't spend a lot of time can
you capture on before the well you can
but after you capture on before you go
nice captures on d4 you eliminate the
defender of the night and after rook
captures you're gonna capture on c3
and this is this was a blacks best bet
because black now has to play c5 but
it's an extremely hard move to find in a
in a rapid game where you no longer have
this weak pawn on c7 but the point is
that you'd have to see that after Queen
captures you can just trade and then
grab on d3 as you can't capture due to
this route captures any one idea and
here you would have a four points
against three pawns black would most
likely be able to defend this but it's a
it's a really tough idea to find in a
rapid game so here also possible not
just wink after Sun before is Knight
captures on e - but if Knight captures
an e2 with check then you get King to f1
and now what do you do here your knight
is attacked three times you capture on
before and you hope that well once the
trades are made on the night you're
gonna grab the b3 Knight the problem is
you can't do this because after rook
captures and rook captures that white
will just recapture with the King that's
the problem now you're just down a piece
so here I'm obsession or we could say
for for the lack of a better move plate
c5 it's a strange idea but he played it
I'm sure there there is some reason
behind it I can't really explain it as
the next move move session plays I don't
see why it couldn't have been played
without the c5 move but I'm sure there
is a reason being accepted the pawn
he played be capture some 3/5 now
creating a very strong pasty pawn and
now I'm obsession captured on e to wit
check being played King to f1 and now
okay you cannot capture anything as the
Queen would be captured but here Queen
to f6 and here we have this idea that
most Asian had I don't know why it
couldn't work while the pawn was still
on c7 why the pond had to be sacrificed
with with c5 but I'm sure I'm missing
something maybe I'm just tired
I really don't know but okay most Asians
idea is now that he wants to sacrifice
the night for Queen to f3 followed by
Queen to h1 mate
now does this work and
can deemed capture the night well deemed
captured it so obviously didn't capture
the night with Queen to three now
threatening Queen to H one mate and now
rook captures an idiot with check of
course you have to play this rook
captures an EI and now how do you
prevent Queen to h1 mate well tink the
g1 this is what being played of course
he prevented me but now you get rook to
a 2 and now the threat is either you win
the Queen or if the Queen moves just
Queen captures an f2 with check followed
by Queen captures on h2 with checkmate
so why did the ding allow this why why
did he get himself in such a position
well feel free to pause the video and
try to find the winning idea for being
in this position while I give you a
couple of seconds for those of you who
were able to do it congratulations you
are an excellent giver of Queens for
winning positions and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show yes you
do have to give up your queen but it's
not really a problem here being played
Queen captures I need to most accion
recaptured and ding just played the c6
and it was in this position that cerium
obsession resigned the game as there is
nothing more to do here for example if
you play pink after Sun b3 just c7 if
you grab the Knight to c8 Queen
this comes with check King moves
captures here and the white is just up a
whole rook this is of course unplayable
and if you somehow try to prevent the
pond from queening let's say go queenie
67 queen c8 you don't really have any
more moves your queen is stuck on c8 and
white will just bring the knight for
example you're gonna play g6 95 you're
gonna play something you can't move the
Queen otherwise eh Queen now you're
gonna go to d6 the Queen is now under
attack you have to move the Queen and
now you don't want to give up the night
for nothing you're just gonna capture
here a pawn
you're gonna Queen now and now again
you're up a whole rook even with the
trade of course completely unplayable so
of course after c6 sir game of station
saw this and in this position he
resigned the game Austria also as a lot
of you have been asking me to show the
stands it's hard to show the standings
as there are so many players left in the
tournament but I will just show you the
pairings for the next
as well it's gonna be really exciting so
here it is usually I check it out on
chest 24 website I'm just gonna enlarge
this the 500% so you can see it better
like this okay so for round three the
pairings are ding will face Alireza phir
aaja so that that's gonna be a really
epic match and even with his 2,700
rating it pales in comparison to dings
the twenty eight hundred and eleven I
think on live ratings dink has now
overtaken Fabiano Caruana as the second
highest rated player in the world but we
still have to wait for next month and
see if that will still hold so Alex anko
will face Hari Krishna we have a linear
Dominguez will face one cow then young
new who will face Alexander Greece shock
also should be very interesting with it
will face Wesley so we have Nikita
vitiligo face Sergey Kerrigan yeah and
the publisher will face Afghani
Tomashevsky young definitely the
favorite in this match but then again
and therefore is the favorite in every
match we have wayy vs you young ji also
another Chinese class we have Jeffrey
Xian versus a nice giri giri really had
an insane game today against the again
in our he had to play nine games against
him to finally beat him in the 90 m to
advance into round three then young
crystal Duda will face Dmitry and rakin
and do the also won all of his games in
the classic section so I think he's
having a very nice run then Elsa Farley
has eliminated Nicholas Arden serene
sorry from the front of video World Cup
really just to two very hard blunders
for Serena and it was all over
so too bad for him but now he faces
sharma media of will be a very tough
match for Safari then we have the new
loofah versus team or a job of we have a
maxim for Cheryl a graph versus admit
react avantco Maxime won all of his
games so far so out of the four games
that he played he scored all four wins
so he's on 100% and Peter Svidler who
eliminated Andre
will face alleviated mississippiana who
eliminated Hikaru Nakamura should be
also a very very exciting metric Maxime
Otacon will face Levon Aronian
and here we have laQuan Liam will face
Vladislav artemyev also known as Chuck
Norris I'm very interested that to see
how far artemyev can take this so that's
pretty much it I do hope you enjoyed it
I would like to thank Kenny Archibald a
Christian Pope couldn't insolia mark
Jensen and twitch streamer for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank all for watching and I will see
you soon
checking up more of the games from the
Vita World Cup checking up on your
wonderful suggestions as usual and so on
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your Sunday